regardez moi cette jolie petite bête ça
c'est la microsoft surface studio laptop
surface laptop studio inverse les mots
je sais pas si je suis dyslexique
pourquoi les inverse les noms sont d'une
très très compliqué je trouve que plus
le temps passe plus les marques se
disent ok on avait une référence on va
rajouter un peu on va rajouter c'est la
gamme surface via un ordinateur
microsoft du studio parce qu'on ne ferme
pas le jeu différente et laptop parce
que ça l'ordinateur et ce tous une
beckett est super intéressante pourquoi
je vous le montre tout de suite
[Musique]
déjà au delà d'avoir un design
extrêmement premium on est en aluminium
c'est hyper canon le fait de pouvoir
venir planqué un style est ici on le
regarde dans quelques instants c'est
vraiment une machine est très très belle
on est sûrs en alu anodisé c'est hyper
hyper hyper cali mais surtout au delà de
ça regardez là vous avez un mode
ordinateur un peu standard c'est à dire
que la gelée hop là ont des zooms un peu
que vous le voyez ça ordinateur il est
comme ça je vais le déverrouiller hop là
windows et l'eau ils me regardent trop
près aux plats y arrive c'est bon il m'a
reconnu que peut-être déverrouiller
c'est bon on déverrouille donc là on
fait le voyez j'ai un ordinateur ça
c'est standard mais comme on en retrouve
studio qui est fait pour les créatifs
qui est plus un usage professionnel et
der garde et je peux prendre ça je
l'emmène sur le devant la tacc donc la
gelée toujours en mode un peu ordinateur
sauf que j'ai plus de clavier j'ai un
petit trackpad donc je peux bien
naviguer je peux venir ouvrir windows
permet de faire des choses donc ça c'est
cool mais je me dis là j'ai pas besoin
de mon clavier puis avec mon style est
en train de griffonner en train de
dessiner et lorsque je veux passer en
mode 100% créatif pas symbole studio que
je continue en fait à dérouler
l'histoire je le prends je le met à plat
et la voyez j'ai un ordinateur à plat
alors attention un peu épais pense pas
du tout les trucs là c'est quand même
relativement épais mais c'est un mode
studio qui est quand même à plat n'est
pas réellement légèrement inclinée vers
moi et là je me mets comme ça je l'avais
au dessus je mets là histoire de vous
montrer et là je peux l'utiliser avec
mon style et je peux venir naviguer je
peux venir ouvrir des trucs ce que veut
dire travailler donc ça c'est vachement
intéressant alors c'est pas pour tout le
monde attendait c'est peut-être pas fait
pour vous si vous voulez un ordinateur
pour faire un peu de bureautique un peu
de gaming c'est franchement pas une
bécane qui va être fait pour nous parce
que on y rajouter quelques fonctions ça
c'est une machine qui est fait pour les
gens qui veulent pouvoir l'utiliser
différentes manières pouvoir le poser
sur les genoux comme ça en mode studio
vous le prenez vous le plus l'attention
sur les genoux l'âme on n'est pas
inquiet 8 a donc ce cas une petite bête
il ya une version i5 une version is est
la version i5 on est inquiet de cet
échec la version is est on et 1 kg 8 et
quelques bons donc il ya quand même un
certain poids on a une certaine
épaisseur c'est pas non plus la machine
est la moins épaisse du monde ce qui
paraît assez assez normal là on va avoir
des aérations pour venir à faire sortir
l'air d'un côté et de l'autre il faut de
la place pour les connectiques en plus
de ça en tout cas nantes c'est que votre
stylet voyez à une petite démarcation là
vous venez vous le prenez vous le posez
alors il aimante et il est bien y tient
il n'y a pas de souci en plus ça vient
recharger sans fil donc c'est hyper
hyper hyper canon donc on a vraiment
c'est trois manières devenir l'aborder
et je trouve ça intéressant c'est à dire
que usage numéro un vous le prenez hop
là je le remonte vous le mettez comme
l'ordinateur un petit peu standard et
bien c'est un ordinateur standard c'est
une bécane de la gamme surface comme on
pourra en utiliser une autre sauf que
celle-ci elle est modulaire ça c'est
vachement bien donc là j'ai mon clavier
je peux venir travailler faire du
traitement de texte de la donne et
saisir faire des emails mais lorsque le
clavier je le veux plus que je veux
vraiment être complètement immergé c'est
là où je viens je pars d'une lumière à
plat le plus en fait je viens l'avancé
et que je viens de mettre la salle
rapproche je lis vraiment plus près ce
sont plus en immersion je suis vraiment
dedans et là je prends mon style et où
pas mon style et là je dis un mot
griffonné je viens naviguer je vais
faire ce que je veux en plus hostile et
là c'est cool parce que regarder ce soir
plusieurs boutons et notamment le bouton
du dessus lorsque j'appuie dessus
regarder hop là ça va m'ouvrir mon
tableau blanc il âgé plus qu'à venir
dessiner griffonné et si je veut
carrément pas m'embêter parce que là je
suis sûre enduro mais si je peux être
sur un bureau le mettre sur les genoux
de me mettre dans mon lit lorsque je
bosse dur star rien fait comme vous
voulez tension alors dans un nid fait
guère facile quand même que les
aérations puis cela je viens dessinée
j'ai griffonné je viens faire ce que je
veux hopla je peux venir après j'appuie
sur le bouton là j'ai un petit bouton
sur le sujet puis hop je viens
sélectionné enfin bref j'ai pas mal
d'options je peux venir faire des petits
trucs en couleurs arc en ciel moi je ne
suis pas particulièrement bon en dessin
je suis pas un créatif qui va dessiner
donc c'est pas du tout mon truc dont je
fais des trucs un peu dégueulasse mais
l'idée c'est ça et cette idée là elle
est géniale modularité on en fait ce
qu'on veut attention ce n'est pas une
tablette souvent on va se dire ben tiens
si je me prends un ipad pro ou que je me
prends la galaxy tab s
ultra que je veux un très gros truc avec
un grand écran je peux venir dessiner
griffonné c'est une certitude ça sera
beaucoup plus léger mais ce ne sera pas
non plus un ordinateur là vous avez un
vrai ordinateur on est sûr de linthal
corps de la série h on assoit i5 soit un
i7 si vous prenez un i5 que vous allez
avoir une intel iris xx e côté graphique
sinon vous avez une nvidia vous avez une
geforce rtx 50 30 pays avec 4 gigas de
mémoire dédiée dont bon ça c'est
vraiment autre chose tout en sachant
qu'ici vous allez aller plus loin
qu'avec une tablette parce que vous avez
soit 16 soit 32 gigas de ram lp délire
4x et vous pouvez monter jusqu'à deux
terrains de stockage ses 256 512 un
terrain de terrain ssd donc voyez c'est
pas la même chose on peut se dire
qu'avec une tablette on peut venir
effectivement dessinée griffonné en
mettant comme ça sauf que là vous avez
un vrai clavier vous avez ce mode là qui
entrejeu qui est très sympa si vous
partez sur 2007 vous avez une vraie
carte graphique brève ou en tout cas est
plus complet qui vous amènera plus loin
qu'avec une tablette c'est une évidence
après il faut vraiment voir vous vos
usages que vous voulez en faire donc là
je vous montre un usage que j'utilise
beaucoup moi par exemple lightroom et je
trouve ça hyper canon alors là c'est
avec la gérer lumière un peu au dessus
mais c'est vraiment ça sera peut-être
pas mal donc je pense que c'est pas la
photo du siècle mais bon on va venir
quand même le faire vous voyez et avec
mon style et souvient directement bosser
la jouer sur les contrastes luminosité
venir la saturer parce que l'on n'est
pas saturé voyez la température des
couleurs qui du coup n'est plus la bonne
bref je peux venir bosser comme ça c'est
génial d'autant plus que vous avez deux
ports usb c'est thunderball 4 vous
pouvez le prendre comme ça vous brancher
un écran externe et vous l'utiliser
comme une tablette graphique alors
attention c'est une tablette graphique
premium de luxe mais ça permet de
compléter un peu l'histoire donc ça
c'est quand même plutôt bien donc à tous
ces usages là que je trouve extrêmement
intéressant ici et puisque je vous parle
des portes on va regarder quand même ce
qui se passe ici donc la voyez je vais
en avoir 2 2 usb ce qui situe juste là
et de l'autre côté alors à mon port
surface connect pour mineurs de
recharger il faut bien leur charge
également du sbc je changerais - vie
puisse convenir la recharge également et
j'ai une prise jack alors c'est
intéressant mais voyez il ya un peu les
limites du truc parce que comme on dit
une bécane qui fait pour des créateurs
des créatifs de la retouche photos du
montage vidéo on pourrait s'attendre et
vu une fois de plus l'épaisseur du
châssis avoir à lecteur de carte sd et
micro sd et là j'ai pas j'ai rien
pourtant j'ai déjà placé en france pour
venir le faire mais ils sont en panne
ils sont dix aujourd'hui peut-être que
les gens vont venir utiliser des petits
meubles pour le faire sauf que si je
mets un petit meuble a effectivement
servir déjà vous condamner un usb c'est
donc c'est tout ce qui est un peu un peu
ballot et on pourrait faire un peu mieux
donc ça vous voyez c'est un poil moyens
il ya un autre truc qui est un poil
moyens et je vous dis tout de suite
c'est l' indice de réparabilité vous
savez c'est le fait de pouvoir démonter
changer réparer facilement on est à 4,6
sur 10 donc ça veut dire que si
potentiellement il ya un truc et on
brade la réparabilité de votre bécane
n'est pas nécessairement garantie ça va
dépendre ce qui va tomber en panne ça
c'est aussi truc à prendre en compte et
c'est dommage parce que la machine ne
trouve super hyper hyper hyper canon
même le maître comme ça on va pas le
faire faut pas mettre comme ça c'est pas
prévu pour mettre comme ça dans ce sens
là mais je peux un peu l'inversé il y
avait un bon clavier de mon côté ça
n'est pas un usage en ce sens
strictement rien il ya d'ailleurs vous
découvrez le de ce côté là il ya un truc
qui fait un peu moins premium c'est ce
petit côté là un petit su derrière alors
qu'on voit les taux allemands n'est pas
censé avoir face à nous et hop on peut
re switcher comme ça notre écran qui
vient tourner alors écran bien
évidemment plus totalement tactile donc
si vous voulez utiliser avec votre doigt
vous pouvez le faire tu actives bell
évidemment parce qu'un stylet sinon ça
ne marcherait pas tout en sachant qu'ici
vous avez un écran avec un taux de
rafraîchissement qui va jusqu'à 120
hertz donc beaucoup de fluidité et une
vraie sensation de dessins sous le doigt
alors on n'a pas le même retour que sur
certaines machines mais on a quand même
une très bonne sensation et c'est très
rapide c'est très réactif très belles
résolutions également dans 2400 par 1600
pixels et un autre point intéressant
c'est qu'on est sur un écran 3 2 me
alors le 3/2 c'est intéressant versus le
16/9 ça l'est un peu moins si vous
regardez une vidéo en plein écran parce
que le 16/9 voyez vous allez bien
pendant toute cette partie là que le 3-2
mais vous avez un peu plus d'écrans pour
de la création c'est pas mal sûr du
divertissement ça va pas gêner les
boudoirs des bords noirs un petit peu en
haut et en bas il faut le savoir autre
truc qui est intéressant avec nous à
fait microsoft ici c'est là que nous en
met 4 haut parleurs pour pouvoir
effectivement profité d'une bonne
expérience audio je ne trouve pas mal
l'expérience audio mais je trouve moins
bonne que sur des macbook pro vous allez
avoir un spectre un peu plus large la
bon on est médium médium plus mais c'est
pas la meilleure expérience qu'on va
venir retrouver ici autres trucs à
savoir et qui est intéressant c'est au
niveau de la charge vous avez dans les
eaux plage vous prend vous avez une
charge qui est différente en fonction si
vous avez une version i5 ou une version
is est sur un 5 vous avez un blog de
charge 65 watts tandis que sur un i7 ce
qui est mon cas ici vous avez
sans doat va donc venir recharger un peu
plus rapidement sur votre i 7 que votre
5 et l'autonomie il faut compter en
toutes choses que vous allez faire nous
allons jusqu'à 17 et 18 heures je crois
chez microsoft là dessus une bonne
dizaine d'heures sans aucun problème un
petit 13 14 heures ça va dépendre du
toit plus de vous de vos usages de la
luminosité de pas mal de petites choses
le truc aussi qui est chouette je vous
montre tout à l'heure c'est windows 2
dont vous venez déverrouiller très
facilement et de façon sécurisée et il
ya un autre point qui est pas mal c'est
que vous avez une caméra directement en
1080p donc on est en full hd la qualité
est plutôt bonne et donc pour venir se
filmer pour venir converser avec des
amis et regardé après m'être déjà comme
ça si vous le souhaitez très facilement
et après vouloir reculer comme ça et là
vous venez le bouger comme vous voulez
comme sur n'importe quelle bécane donc
ça c'est pratique une fois de plus dans
l' usage plus professionnel
alors tout en sachant qu'ici on tombe
bien évidemment sur un windows windows
ou j'en ai déjà parlé il ya quelques
mois vous expliquer un peu les bénéfices
au delà d'avoir un menu démarrer qui est
au centre est pas mal de choses qui ont
été un peu modifié regrouper recentrer
windows aux c'est quand même hyper canon
aller jeter un petit coup d'oeil sur ma
vidéo si vous ne l'avez pas vu pour tout
savoir effectivement sur cette nouvelle
expérience de microsoft aux points et
non des moindres à connaître on va
revenir un mode un peu standard c'est ce
clavier alors le clavier du pam
attention c'est pas le meilleur clavier
que j'ai pu connaître mais plutôt pas
mal bon retour de touche on retrouve
très facilement ses touches il est assez
large donc plutôt bien aux points
également à venir voir c'est le trackpad
retour haptique donc on a pas de bouton
ici c'est totalement de la petit qu'on a
un peu tous les côtés je trouve très
très agréable ce trackpad est assez
grand on pourrait vouloir encore un peu
plus grand mais déjà comme il est là je
trouve plutôt bien il ya un bon
équilibre clavier versus trackpad donc
ça c'est chouette truc que j'aurais pu
trouver bien également et qui a peu en
tout la vie c'est le duo peut-être que
si nous avait mis des petits haut
parleurs là ç'aurait maximiser la
direction l'idée du son et l'expérience
sonore bon peut-être des choses à voir
pour les années suivantes génération
soit en tout cas profité également de
deux micros studios l'ont portée pour
venir converser directement sont pas des
micros studio pour venir enregistrer du
sont professionnels mais pour venir
parler l'expérience est correct et ça
ira autre chose qui est bien cette
bécane comme on en 2022 et bien
forcément on a les techno 2022 man wifi
6e ici mais du wifi 6 alors soyons
clairs là-dessus microsoft ne vient pas
chercher le quidam lambda ils viennent
pas chercher l'utilisateur moyen de
machines ils viennent vraiment ciblé les
pros ils viennent chercher si les gens
qui veulent des usages un petit peu
mixte qui veulent pouvoir utiliser
l'ordinateur de différentes manières
dans différentes configurations que vous
l'utilisiez aussi bien sur vos genoux
que vous l'utilisiez en mode ordinateur
standard que vous l'utilisiez
effectivement dans le mode vous allez
rapprocher l'écran et venir à dessiner
dessus si vous l'utilisez comme ça c'est
que vous utilisez un style et si vous
utilisez un stacy vous êtes soit dans la
productivité ont vraiment très pro
business soit un créatif un illustrateur
que vous fassiez de la retouche photo
sur lightroom sur photoshop que vous
utilisiez autodesk il ya des tonnes de
cas d'usagé on peut venir faire
l'édition vidéo sur un premier à messi
sans problème dont vous voyez que c'est
une machine qui est un peu un couteau
suisse du créateur du créatif qu'on peut
mettre un peu dans tous les sens on peut
promener partout avec soi il ya quelques
points un peu négatif je vous dis même
si elle est pas trop trop loin d'être
quand même sont presque son petit deux
kilos kg 7 1 kg 8 on a un petit peu
d'épaisseur il manque quelques
connectique c'est pas grave et elle
tient même à la verticale tellement
qu'elle était celle et quand même cool
elle est quand même très sympa moi
j'aime bien j'aime bien ces innovations
j'aime bien des machines qui sont un peu
différentes qui viennent un peu casser
le marché qui viennent proposer d'autres
choses parce qu'un ordinateur c'est
assez standard il ya forcément la
puissance qui aimerait bien jouer en
contre mais il n'ya pas que la puissance
ça c'est intéressant parce que voyez je
trouve que microsoft avec cette machine
là elle est un peu dans l'idée des
dizaines book pro duo que nous propose
asus est à dire on a des choix qui sont
vraiment différents ils peuvent venir
séduire des créateurs des créatifs des
professionnels parce que les machines
change un peu des autres et ça c'est
cool donc ça j'aime beaucoup donc si
vous voulez une très belle expérience
microsoft ici que vous êtes créateur
vous êtes créatif que vous êtes jean
sérien influenceurs ou pourquoi pas ce
que vous voulez et que vous voulez
utiliser un joli stylo à vous avez une
super machine alors aipac à dos 1 vous
avez plusieurs confie que je vous les
donne il ya certaines omissions de suite
si vous êtes sur le i5 16 giga de ram
256 go de stockage on commence à 1699
euros sachant qu'en ce moment il ya une
promo à 1449 qui est plutôt cool vous
montez au site vous avez trahi 5,16 512
vous passez ensuite ans il cède 16 500
12 étages à 2199 c'est un peu plus haut
il cède 32 un terreau à
2799 et le i7 32,2 terreur de terrain a
tranché ce qui est plutôt pas mal 3199
qu'il ya des promos il ya des hommes
voulaient tous les liens en bas dans la
description attention je vous le dis une
fois de plus cette machine n'est pas
fait pour tout le monde mais si vous
cherchez de la modularité pour la
productivité pour la création elle est
juste hyper canon elle pas parfaite mais
elle est hyper canon et moi j'aime
beaucoup donc je compte sur vous pour
dire ce que vous en pensez en bas ou
comment dire comment vous la trouvez
vous cette g cham non je leur fais
jamais parker s'est jamais les mots dans
le désordre des fois microsoft surface
laptop studio très chouette ray kahno
dit pas tout ça en bas en commentaire ne
testera d'autres des ordinateurs y en a
qui vont arriver un petit peu pour lui
dit pas tout parce que ce n'est pas tout
vous dire mais y'en a qui vont ruiner
donc on en reparle très bientôt d'ici là
prenez soin de vous soyez sages on
reparle de bécanes je vous emmène en
voyage beaucoup de voyages qui arrive à
beaucoup déplacé c'est super chouette
croyez moi de très bons moments en
perspective nous embrasse à bientôt ciao
[Musique]